'Throughout a very soggy British summer,
'12 brave bakers battled it out over bain maries and baking trays
'to impress the Bake Off's very own king and queen of cakes,
'Mary Berry and Paul Hollywood.'
The standard has gone up and up.
That texture is excellent.
We raised the bar and all of them, fortunately, have leapt over it.
'Each week, the bakers faced three challenges
'that tested their baking experience,
'their creativity and their ability to work under pressure.'
Dicing with death in the marquee of the Great British Bake Off.
'As the heat was turned up, some of them started to crack.'
Look at the state of me, my hands are shaking.
I can't do it.
'But it was the signature bakes that said most
'about the bakers themselves.
'A tried and tested recipe of their own
'that would wow Mary and Paul's palette.'
I'm just making things today that I like.
Could go great, could go catastrophically bad.
- You've worked all that out, haven't you?
- I think so.
It does work quite well at home and everybody really likes it.
'But now it's time for Mary and Paul to demonstrate
'some of their own Signature Bakes,
'and see what they'd have done in the bakers' shoes.'
I'm quite looking forward to putting my own personality
into the Signature Challenge.
I've got lots of hints and tips to give people.
And I just hope everybody at home likes it
and wants to bake it themselves.
'Coming up, Paul makes his own flat breads with a twist,
'combining a smooth camembert with quince jelly.
'Perfect for any picnic.
'Mary's own signature recipe for the perfect apple tarte tatin -
'crisp apples and golden caramel with a puff pastry base.
'Paul's recipe for beef Wellington - a fillet of beef wrapped in pate
'and delicious laminated real puff pastry.
'Mary's signature sponge pudding -
'a deliciously light apple sponge soaked in sticky toffee sauce,
'and Paul's signature regional buns -
'his twist on the classic Chelsea bun
'combines dried fruit and cinnamon with orange icing.
'And finally, if you've ever wanted to know how to crimp pies,
'line a tin or make Danish pastries, Mary and Paul show us
'all the tricks in a series of quick tips.'
With baking, you never stop learning.
This is our chance to show you guys how to bake at home properly.
If everybody follows these stages, you'll get a perfect result.
Let it be your signature dish.
'Week two of the bake-off and the bakers were battling with bread.
'They created a huge range of show-stopping bagels,
'and got themselves into a knot with Paul's eight-stranded plaited loaf
'in the technical challenge.
'But the day started off flat with the Signature Challenge.'
Today, it's the Signature Bake,
and what we're looking for are flat breads.
Now these can be tortilla, naan, roti, anything you like.
You can bake them any way you want. So...
- On your marks.
- Get set. BOTH: Bake.
I'm doing a spiced mango naan bread.
Garlic, parsnip and black cardamom chapattis.
A Bombay bread,
so if you've ever had Bombay mix it's kind of the same flavour.
This is traditional Chinese bread.
I'm making some Italian-style flat breads.
This is my mum's recipe that I'm using,
and I'm not changing anything, so hopefully it should still work.
Fingers crossed.
Paul's twist on the Signature Flat Bread Challenge is his recipe
for fresh dough combined with rich camembert and quince jelly.
I've been making flat breads like this,
and certainly this technique, for the last...
- HE EXHALES
- ..years, a long time.
Flat breads go back right into history.
For today's, I'm going to be using yeast,
you can make it with a sour,
but I'm going to modernise it by adding camembert and quince.
Very simple to do, actually, and great for dinner parties.
Weigh 500 grams of strong white flour into a mixing bowl,
add 10 grams of salt to one side
and 7 grams of fast action yeast to the other.
The yeast is obviously the leavening bit,
this is the bit that's going to put a bit of air in it
and give it a bit of punch when you put it on to the skillet to bake it.
And then a good glug of, it's about 20, 30 grams of olive oil,
straight in.
The next thing I'm going to add is my water,
- a little bit to start with.
- Right.
Fingers like a mixer, just mix it in, turn the bowl round.
Could I do that in a mixer?
You could do it in a mixer, use your dough hook, not a paddle.
I'm using cold water, most people when they're making doughs
- would use warm water, you know.
- Yes, I would.
But cold water will still rise the bread, it just takes longer
and it's the length of time that it proves gives you the flavour.
So a long prove gets the best bread.
Long prove, more flavour, less prove, less flavour.
So are you doing it to the same consistency that you would do
for an ordinary white bread?
A normal white bread, yeah.
That looks about right.
I've picked up most of the flour now on the bowl.
Pour some olive oil onto the bench before kneading the dough.
Don't use flour as it will tighten the dough
and restrict it from growing.
What you're trying to do is shape it into some sort of starting position
and it's nearly there, a bit of pounding.
When you're making bread, it takes a lot of energy out of you
- and if you're feeling a bit cross and angry...
- Absolutely.
..it releases it, but you're feeling all right today.
No, I feel fine today.
You knead this for about four or five minutes.
If you're going to do it by hand, take your time if you want to,
you can take up to ten minutes, it's literally the weight of your hand
that's doing it and a little bit of a stretch and then roll up.
It's a very simple technique, it doesn't take
a lot of muscle at all, it's just the weight of your arm.
And then you're looking for a soft consistency like this.
Yes, still quite sticky.
Yes, it is, and all you do is, once you've mixed it for a bit,
five to ten minutes, depending on how fast you're going to go,
you then place the whole thing back in the bowl,
get a bit of olive oil in there
and just leave it to rest for about ten to 15 minutes.
'But the bakers were just as determined to prove that they
'could impress Paul with their dough.'
I'm captivated by your yeast slapping.
It's very, very easy to overwork dough
if you use the dough hook on the blender.
Whereas it's a lot more difficult to do that
when you're doing it by hand.
A nice action, by the way.
- Thank you.
- A very nice action.
- Cheers.
Just waiting for everything now, calm before the storm.
What yeast have you got in there?
Well, this is my Shetlandic homemade style.
- Can I have a smell?
- Yeah, go for it. Eight years old, that one.
- Eight years old.
- No way!
Yeah, that's...that's nice, that. It's nice and active.
I'm waiting for the flavours to meld in the roti
and then it starts the cooking.
Mary, can you bring that dough for me, please? Thank you.
That looks well-risen.
You can see in that short space of time it's risen,
it's got some air in it, some flour, tip this dough out.
So why have you changed to flour?
Because I'm not mixing now, the dough's already done.
Despite being a flat bread, the dough still needs to prove.
Although you're going to roll this thing out and put it onto a pan
and technically fry it to rise it up,
the bubbles still need to be formed
and the flavour still needs to be incorporated into the dough.
Just stretch the dough out
and just cut it into about roughly 70 gram balls.
- I think you've done this before.
- A couple of times.
I'm making balls because it's easier to roll out a basic shape.
So 70 grams is going to make quite big ones, isn't it?
You can do them the size of your frying pan.
If you've got a big frying pan, make them bigger,
if you've got a small frying pan, make them smaller.
Once your dough is ready, prepare your fillings.
You can choose almost anything to fill these flat breads,
but Paul is using camembert and quince.
I'm just going to take a blob of the camembert and pop it
inside the dough, just going to take a little bit of the quince jelly.
And now you've got to make a little parcel, basically,
by pinching up the sides and pinching it together.
Once you've got the little parcel, use your rolling pin
and just gently stretch it out.
You will get a slight burst as the cheese
and the quince tries to get out.
Now, when your pan's nice and hot,
I always test it with a little flick of flour,
to see if it actually goes brown.
Could you do it in a normal non-stick frying pan?
Yeah, yeah. Use a little bit of oil.
No more proving for that like you would with a roll?
Well, no, it's flat, we proved it in the bowl
to give it a bulk fermentation to give it flavour.
What we're doing now is actually forcing the yeast to start to grow,
it will start to bubble very, very quickly
because it's on extreme heat.
- See the bubbles beginning to appear all the way around?
- Yes.
- All over the top, they're bubbling.
- It's rising, isn't it?
- It is.
- If you're going camping and you've got a frying pan,
you could easily make this sort of bread.
What fun to do out of doors!
Yes, absolutely, and the kids love doing this as well.
It's quite versatile. Put stilton, put grapes, put pecans,
put mushroom, onions, anything you want, inside these.
And the range of recipes which the bakers made
showed just how varied these breads can be.
That's how it's meant to look, sort of, isn't it?
If they puff up like they are doing here, then they're cooked,
the puffing up is key.
You don't have to make flat breads in a frying pan.
Many of the bakers did theirs in the oven,
in all kinds of different ways.
I'm trying to juggle lots of things, I've got the griddle on the go
and the pizza stone.
They're calling you Hot Rocks Brendan.
It's a bit like, I suppose, the equivalent of our stone bake theory.
- Stone bake pizza?
- Exactly, there's just an extra quality, isn't there?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There's an extra taste.
The cheese is beginning to cook, the quince is beginning to melt
and it's beginning to blow bubbles, see, and then steam pours out.
Smells wonderful.
As a party food, it works really well because you just chop them
into lengths and serve them with an aubergine guacamole dip,
which is one of my favourites because there's actually
colour in the dough with some curry powder, it turns it green and you
add a spoonful of sultanas and some mango chutney to that as well.
A whole curry in a flatbread.
I mean, anything works inside these things.
Get a good strong colour on it, don't be afraid to put
this little bit of black on it, that's what it should be.
About three or four minutes each side.
You leave that to cool and then chop it up while it's warm,
and then you'll get all the ooze coming out of it.
It's absolutely delicious,
but that is how you make a camembert and quince flat bread.
Steaming. I've got the big half.
So these can be done in advance and then warmed just before a party.
I like the way it's so flexible,
and you can imagine filling it with all things like
a little bit of curry in there with a little bit of mango chutney.
You can taste that camembert as well.
The camembert's in there, little bit of quince I've just got as well.
And together with the look of them, they're just, for me,
they're fantastic flat breads.
And so easy to make.
- Well, I think they're absolutely lovely.
- Good.
Now Mary's top tip for perfectly lining a circular cake tin.
First of all, I have got to grease the tin.
Right in the corners.
And then all the way around the sides.
So you just take a strip of baking parchment,
and it wants to be taller than the tin
because it deflects the heat from the side.
And take the strip and then fold in a piece at the bottom...
..like that.
So I've turned that in, then I'm going to cut diagonal slices,
all the way down.
As you put that in the tin,
each one will overlap the other quite easily.
So lift the paper up and where you've done that straight fold,
that's got to go to the bottom of the tin.
Press that all the way around.
That's perfect.
Then you just take the circle that you've cut,
pop that over the top, and it's as neat as can be.
Tin is lined, so all you've got to do is put the mixture in
and just level it off.
The third week of the bake-off was all about tarts.
Mary's treacle tarte tangled them up in the technical challenge
whilst their show-stopping designer tarts had the wow factor.
But it was with their Signature Bake
that the bakers hoped to impress.
Now we're going to be asking you today to rustle up
a bit of a French classic, which is the tarte tatin.
So we're looking for one large tarte,
which sounds like a Paul Hollywood personal ad.
But it isn't, we're looking for a classic tarte tatin,
- sweet or savoury. So...
- On your marks.
- Get set.
- Bake.
Whilst traditionally apple,
the bakers put their own twist on the classic tarte tatin.
I am making an apple and pear tarte tatin.
Apple and lavender.
- Apple and vanilla.
- An apple and ginger tarte tatin.
Others went even further.
Blue cheese and walnut and a bit of thyme.
Plum, cherry and five spice tarte tatin.
- Caramelised banana.
- Oh, nice, that's my favourite one, that.
- Oh, is it?
- Yes.
- That was lucky.
But Mary's signature tarte tatin is the traditional apple,
glazed in their own juices
and layered with a homemade rough puff pastry.
I think this is one of my favourite challenges, actually,
the signature tarte tatin.
I couldn't agree more, it's a French classic,
I'm doing my own interpretation of it. I'm going to start off
with the pastry, and I'm doing a quick rough puff.
Weigh out 100 grams of plain flour and 50 grams of butter
and 25 grams of lard that you've frozen, ready to grate.
If you don't have it really, really cold, it won't grate.
Put the lard into the flour, and in this way it doesn't really
stick to your hands, otherwise you'll get in a real mess.
Now you see what I'm doing here
is keeping every little bit of fat separate.
You know, rather than having big lumps,
which is traditional for rough puff or little pieces for flaky.
Do the same with the frozen butter until everything is grated
and incorporated with the flour.
This is how I make pastry at home, very quickly,
whether it's a mince pie, any pastry that I want nice and flaky.
The colder the butter inside the pastry,
the more rise and puff you will get.
People say you've got to have cold hands for pastry.
I'm not too fussy whether my hands are cold,
it's having the actual fat cold.
Add about four or five tablespoons of water to the grated mixture.
Combine the ingredients until the pastry holds together
and it's ready to roll out.
Flour the board.
My nan used to use a lot of lard, you know, in a lot of her baking,
you know, especially round World War One.
Did you use a lot of lard then as well?
You're always on about me cooking in the war!
- You are rotten to me, aren't you?
- Sorry, Mary.
Roll it into an oblong, like that,
and you can see how well the fat is distributed.
So a good indication actually
is looking for a good marble in this from the very beginning?
That's right. I'm going to fold that in three, like that,
brush off any surplus flour, then again like that.
Seal the ends to keep the air in, and then one in the middle
and there, and gradually you will build up layers,
just as if you were doing real puff pastry.
Repeat exactly the same folding sequence for a second time.
I just put my knuckle in like that,
so when I take it out of the fridge, it reminds me that I've done two.
Wrap it in cling film and put the pastry in the fridge to chill.
You'll need to repeat the folding process once more,
chilling it in the fridge in between
to prevent it from shrinking when baked.
In the meantime, make the caramel.
When making caramel, you have to have a pan that is stainless steel,
not non stick, or it will crystallise very quickly.
Add six tablespoons of water to a pan
and then dissolve 175 grams of granulated sugar.
It's no good trying to do this with any of the brown sugars,
it doesn't work, you've got to have a white sugar.
Stir until all the sugar is dissolved
and then leave alone to boil rapidly for a few minutes.
And you'll immediately notice that it starts to make a row.
When it reaches the caramel stage, it will go peaceful,
but don't wander round the kitchen, stay with it and watch it.
Can you see in the middle there
it's just beginning to turn the palest caramel colour?
Although some of the bakers didn't find making caramel quite so easy.
I think the sugar crystallised, so I'm going to start again.
The pressure is definitely on at the moment
as the caramel is going on for the fourth time.
How many times have you done that?
This is the fifth one and this is the sixth time.
Watch these like a hawk, please.
- I know.
- SHE LAUGHS NERVOUSLY
I've got a good feeling about number six.
This sugar syrup is batch seven. Oh, please don't go crystallise now.
I don't think the sugar likes me today.
Now, that is just a gorgeous deep toffee colour.
Pour that in quite quickly, don't grease this,
if you grease it, as soon as the caramel goes in there,
it will crystallise.
I will use that pan to make the sort of syrup to go off the top,
so I can just leave that.
Then run that just round the bottom,
and leave it to get absolutely cold, and then you put the apples on top.
Slice 900 grams of eating apples into thin wedges.
Don't use cooking apples as they will disintegrate while baking.
I'm using Pink Lady because I'm leaving the skin on
and they look very pretty.
You could use Cox's, you could use any eating apple,
and they need to be fairly evenly cut into wedges,
especially on the bottom because you've got to make that pattern,
which looks so pretty.
Now, when you come to doing the apple, the natural thing to do
is to put them in like that, but when you think about it,
it's going to be turned out,
so what you've got to do is put them that way round,
and then you get that lovely pattern all the way round.
Take the slices and just go all the way round in the circle,
overlapping, and you only need do this for the bottom,
or rather it will turn out as the top.
You can just chuck the rest in on top.
Add the juice of the lemon to the sliced apples
to prevent them from going brown.
I must say, you're doing this very meticulously and I'm very impressed.
Thanks very much, Mum. Did you ever see Fanny Craddock, Mary?
She had Johnny of course,
but I treat you much nicer than Fanny Craddock treated Johnny.
Add the lemon zest to the remaining apple slices
and pile them all into the tin.
So there it is full, now we have to put the pastry on top.
Remove the chilled pastry from the fridge.
It has already had three turns and is now ready for the final one.
So one more rolling in the traditional way
to get those folds and all the layers,
and now all I've got to do is roll it to the shape of the tin.
It wants to be just a little bit bigger.
How you know how big it is, take the length of the rolling pin,
put your nail there, that's plenty big enough.
And then just lift it into the middle and gently ease it in,
tucking it in.
Can you see that it is a little bit on the big side?
But that's how it should be.
Pushing it down, you don't need to do any fancy edging with it,
tucking it in all the way round, and then take a knife
and just make a little cross in the middle to let the apples breathe
and send some steam out.
Put in a pre-heated oven at 220 degrees,
200 fan, for about 40 minutes until the pastry is golden.
There's a lot of liquid still.
Moment of truth now.
HE SIGHS
It's kind of collapsed slightly on this side, but...
Well, that's not too bad.
Puff the magic pastry, here it comes.
God, you need biceps for that.
That's not only a taste of France, it's the size of France.
Oh, my days. Look at that.
Yes, yes, sorry. Yes.
The main thing is the pastry is cooked through, the apples are soft,
it's shrinking away from the sides a little,
and I'm going to drain off any surplus juices
and add a little more sugar to it.
Add 75 grams of caster sugar
to the pan that you used to make the caramel.
Put a cloth over the top and drain any juices into that pan.
In that way, you get a nice syrup. And reduce it.
There's a little bit of caramel that was left from the caramel
that I put at the base, it's a nice coating consistency now,
and that will give a really nice shine on top.
So that's ready. We'll turn it out and pour the sauce over the top.
You never want to turn it out until you're serving
so everybody's sitting down,
everybody's anticipating it coming in, turn it out then.
So put the plate over the top like that, a wing and a prayer...
One, two, three.
Like that.
There we are, looks beautiful,
and you see the way we had that pastry just pushed down.
Yeah.
It makes a lovely rim and then the extra sauce over the top.
Now, doesn't that give a lovely shine to it?
Can I eat it now, Mary?
There's no sugar with the apple, that's intentional,
you have the caramel at the top, and when the juices are drained off,
you add more sugar, and that is the only sweetener.
The flavour of the apple really comes through on this one.
- Lovely crispy, buttery base.
- And I think it works.
That would be lovely with cream and stuff, beautiful.
And now Paul's top tip to create a crimping crown for any pie.
Grab the lid and pop it on top of the pie.
A bit of pressure pushing your lid onto your base,
just seals it all in so everything cooks within the pie.
Lift up your pie, hold the knife at an angle,
trim all the way around, nice and gently.
The crimping is mainly for aesthetics.
Start with two fingers on the corner, your next finger,
your forefinger, then comes up and drives up a little arch like so.
Go all the way around.
That is one style of crimping.
The next one is, just your thumb and your forefinger.
Pinch, pinch on the edge of your pie, and it seals the lid
and the base neatly and it looks very professional.
You can seal a pork pie like this or any pie.
Look at that.
Week five of the bake-off and the remaining eight bakers
were challenged to make Paul's technically tricky hand-raised pies
and wow the judges with their show-stopping American pies.
But it was the Signature Challenge
that showed their twist on a puff pastry family favourite.
Bakers, we'd like you to make a Wellington.
The filling has to be savoury, it needs to be completely covered
with pastry, but the rest is up to you, so on your marks...
- Get set.
- Bake.
I'm calling it a full English Wellington
because it's got eggs, sausage, black pudding, tomato and mushroom.
Chick peas, peppers and spinach,
and then it's going to have some garlic mushrooms around it.
I'm making a salmon coulibiac
with layers of different types of vegetables and herbs.
We all like a challenge.
Paul's signature Wellington is a classic beef Wellington
with puff pastry spread with pate
and wrapped around a prime fillet of tender beef.
So, beef Wellington, this is one of the real luxury dishes.
I'm looking forward to your version.
Today, I'll go down the classical route but for me, my twist
is adding the pate, and all the flavours together are just stunning.
Measure out 150 grams of strong flour and 150 grams of plain flour.
You're dumbing down the gluten in the strong,
but you're upping the gluten from the plain,
so the balance actually would be quite a robust pastry
that you can really roll out and slap your butter in
and get some rise from.
Add to the flour a pinch of salt and two whole eggs
and 100 millilitres of water, a little at a time.
Get your fingers in again, begin to mix the pastry round,
you can do this in a mixer,
essentially, it will just do this, that you can do with your hand.
It's quite a robust little dough.
Once you've taken all the flour that's in the bowl,
pop it on the bench.
A light dusting of flour and then just roll it up into a ball,
and all you do is manipulate this, just for a couple of minutes,
just until it goes smooth, and it will go smooth.
Again, the technique, just flatten it down,
and then roll it up.
Flatten it down and roll it up. You only literally
have to bring the ingredients together for a couple of minutes
just doing this, and you can see the dough is much smoother.
It's quite stretchy as well.
It's got a bit of resistance in there.
Proper puff pastry must be chilled, or it can become tough,
so wrap it in Clingfilm and chill in the fridge for as long as possible -
overnight, if you have time.
It's quite enjoyable to make your own puff pastry -
when it turns out right.
Everything is tricky about this bake - the meat, the pastry,
the bits that you put with it. And they all have to be good.
The secret with making...
puff is obviously to keep
your ingredients as cold as possible.
I'm going to use a bit of flour and a rolling pin
and just shape it, so it's nice and smooth,
into a rectangle.
Measure out 160g of very cold, unsalted butter...
Coat it in flour.
It is hard - you can put it between greaseproof and bang it out.
Just keep it on a bench, and bang it out.
Very good tip, to have it on a board, to do it.
Yeah. It doesn't make THAT much mess,
as long as your butter's cold.
Make it into a rough rectangle.
When you put the butter on the dough,
it must cover two-thirds of it.
I'm going to fold over the top bit now
over half the butter, to about there.
But to make it even more accurate, just cut your butter,
lift it up, pop it on the top.
Stretch the bottom, then place that over the top.
Now, that looks very neat. The only difference is,
when I make puff pastry, I do it the classic way,
of equal butter to equal flour,
and no egg in it - so, this is a totally different version.
Egg is one of the key ingredients for flavour,
and also for the spring as well.
- It'll also give it a nice colour.
- Yeah, golden.
- I'm interested.
Tap the middle,
and then tap down and tap up.
If you start from the top and tap, all the butter
runs down to the bottom, so start tapping gently from the middle,
up and down, little bit of a roll...
You're taking it down roughly to about...10 mil, in height.
Once you've got that nice and neat - and try and get it
as neat as you can -
then you fold it one more time.
That...is one turn.
Tap it in the middle again, up and down,
and then roll out again, to exactly the same size
as you did a minute ago.
Fold it again, and once more, over the top.
Now, that...has had two turns.
Now, it needs another two before you use it.
Now, that will go straight into a fridge,
and be left to chill, again, for at least an hour,
or even a couple of hours, till that butter
begins to solidify, and then we can do a final two turns,
and it's ready to go. This is 750 grams
of prime fillet steak. There's no way of doing
a half-measure with this - you have to go for quality.
You can get the butcher to clean it up, but if you do see any sinews,
just drop your knife under and run it through.
Now, this has been outside for a couple of hours -
just in ambient temperature, room temperature, just to relax the meat.
Because as soon as it goes into the fridge, it tightens up.
You want it to be nice and loose.
And most important of all, it must be
- the centre cut...
- Yeah.
- ..because the tail comes here - that's thin,
- and you wouldn't get the even size all the way down.
- Yeah.
And the thick end here comes in two parts, and clever butchers
tie it all together, but when you take a slice from it,
- it's in two pieces.
- Breaks apart, yeah.
So, it should be the centre cut, which, I'm afraid,
- is the most expensive cut.
- Unfortunately, yes, it is.
I'm just going to seal the steak off in a pan.
Rub some salt in, and some pepper,
get it inside the pan.
STEAK SIZZLES
Pop some kitchen roll on here,
and just to take a little bit more of that juice off...
And you need to leave that to cool.
- Stone cold, otherwise it will melt the butter in the pastry.
- Exactly.
But that was the least of the worries in the bake-off tent.
Oh!
It's a little bit unstable.
This feels so funny!
I can't decide whether to decorate or to score.
- I'd decorate it.
- You reckon? I might decorate it.
And you know how Mary loves to see what's on the inside
- replicated on the outside...?
- Oh, no, don't!
- I haven't got...
- I think you should do a full farmyard scene.
Pastry here, which I'm now going to roll out,
ready to have the steak put inside.
You've got to think of the size of the fillet,
which I've sort of got in my head.
Now relax the pastry. Get a bit of air underneath it.
You can see it's not springing back at all. Now's the fun bit.
I've got about 150 grams of pate.
Just begin to smear it onto the top of the puff pastry.
As long as you get the majority of it equally down the middle that way,
it doesn't matter too much
cos that's the bit that's going to be folded over
so you don't have to go right to the end.
Do you know, one of the things I like about beef Wellington
is that you can do it all ahead, you can actually assemble it completely,
everything except for glazing it.
Keep it in the fridge,
do it the day before and then cook it in the oven.
It will take a little bit longer.
Got my rectangle here, I'm just going to tack a little bit down
on the table. This just helps when you finally roll it up,
you've got something thin to actually join on to.
So get your fillet, the size is pretty good,
pop that into the centre, get the top piece
and then just try and tack that down on to the steak,
keeping that quite tight.
Fold your ends in, the same on the other side.
It's funny how I learn something every day, I would never think
of doing this business of pressing the pastry like you are there
and pressing it down so it doesn't move, that's a very good tip.
Yeah, it prevents it from moving but also when you
seal it up you've got a nice thin line,
because when you roll that over now you can pull it and get a bit
of a tension and then you know it's going to be nice and neat,
and you know underneath you've got the one line
which is already self-tacked.
Egg wash the Wellington so that it is covered all over,
giving the pastry its golden colour.
That'll give it a nice shine.
You don't have to grease the baking sheet
because there's plenty of butter in the pastry and it won't stick.
Use the back of your knife and just run it from the top,
don't put any weight on it, and just drop it down.
Just doing diagonals.
That's a lovely simple, smart way of doing it.
- You can put leaves on top.
- Yeah.
- And any trimmings if you want to.
But don't use the sharp part of your knife,
cos the last thing you want to do is cut through the pastry
and then cause it to rip in the oven.
That will give it a lovely pattern on top when it's cooking.
Bake in the oven for 20 to 25 minutes at 200 degrees fan,
until the pastry is crisp and golden and cooked all the way through.
But not all the bakers were so lucky.
OK, you need to go in.
Oh, my god almighty.
My pastry has completely melted and is falling off the meat.
There's absolutely nothing I can do about it.
This is like the worst thing, ever.
Oh!
Well, actually...ooh, hello!
The pastry looks good.
- That looks fantastic.
- One of the reasons why it puffs up so much
is if you take it straight from the fridge and put it in the oven,
that sting from being from the fridge where it's cold
and hits the heat, it just wants to explode
cos all the layers of butter are really cold.
That's the secret to making a great puff pastry.
And that for me
is the best beef Wellington.
It's lovely, it's golden brown.
You need to rest this for a good ten, 15 minutes
before you actually serve it.
- And that's a very important part, isn't it?
- Yeah.
Is your plate ready?
Thank you.
Oh, that's just how I like it.
That's grand that, Mary. Especially with the pate.
I think it's lovely.
- Just going to carry on eating, cos it's delicious!
- Oh, it's good.
And now Paul's top tip to create the perfect Danish pastry shapes.
Get your pastry, roll it out and then trim it off
so you have four squares.
Two ends into the middle,
that's your first shape.
The second shape, into the middle for the two corners,
and then again into the middle. The next one is a bit more complicated.
Cut out from the middle to each corner.
Pick a corner, fold it into the middle, miss the next one,
and then fold the next one into the middle.
Fold the next, that's called the Catherine wheel.
The last one, cut round, nearly to the corners,
make sure you cut all the way through, the same on the other side.
Cut along and then down.
Take the piece, place it over the other side,
the other piece to the other side, and there you have it.
Four different Danish pastry shapes.
The final seven bakers had to
put their money where their mouths were in pudding week.
From a regal technical challenge making the queen of puddings
to a show-stopper that saw them struggling to make strudel pastry.
But the proof of this pudding was in the Signature Challenge.
We'd like you to make two different flavoured sponges
with two different accompaniments.
They should be individual sized portions, please,
and they can be baked, boiled or steamed.
So on your marks.
Get set.
Bake.
I feel a bit panicky already, which is not a good way to start.
If we can't knock a couple of sponge puddings up in two hours,
then we don't deserve the accolade of even being here.
Today, I'm making a ginger sponge pudding with brandy cream
and also a chocolate fondant with malt ice cream.
A chocolate pudding.
My accompaniment is actually going to be Jubilee cherries.
I chose Clootie dumplings because they are traditionally Scottish.
There are no two recipes of Clootie dumpling the same,
everyone's got their own different recipes.
Raspberry and white chocolate puddings with a basil ice cream.
I'm not a multi-tasker but I'm doing literally a million things.
Mary's signature sponge pudding
is her sticky toffee apple and pecan pud.
A light apple steamed sponge
smothered in rich toffee and pecan sauce.
Sponge puddings, Mary. One of my all time favourites.
So to start off, let's make the toffee sauce, very easy.
Measure out 300 millimetres of pouring cream into a saucepan,
100 grams of light muscovado sugar and 75 grams of softened butter.
So sensible to weigh the butter on top of the sugar.
It'll slip out easily and we can use the pan without washing it up.
In goes the sugar, in goes the butter.
It's just a matter of stirring that together until the sugar dissolves.
You just do it on a low heat and just cook it for about five minutes
until it's a sauce consistency.
While that's getting going I'm going to well butter a two pint basin.
Weigh out 125 grams of light muscovado sugar
and the same again of butter and place into a large mixing bowl.
So in goes the sugar and lovely soft butter.
I'm going to make this the creaming method,
that's putting the butter and the sugar together,
creaming it until smooth and then we're going to add the eggs.
Why are you doing it that way, then?
Just for a change, I always do the all in one
and sometimes people say, "Why don't you do it the creaming?"
It takes a bit longer but many people do it this way.
So mix it until it's smooth.
Mix together the ingredients until everything is completely combined
and it gets lighter in colour.
Add in a beaten egg a little bit at a time
and weigh out 125 grams of self-raising flour.
And you're doing me 125 grams?
I'm doing it right now.
Yeah, OK. Am I nagging you?
- Yeah, you are.
- I've still got some egg to add.
At this stage it sometimes curdles.
Therefore I'm going to add a little of the flour
to the egg, butter and sugar mixture and that will just stabilise it.
Whisk in the rest of the egg and add a teaspoon of vanilla extract.
Peel and chop up one large cooking apple,
or one and a half smaller ones into very small chunks,
about the size of a pea.
So you have to do it in reasonably small pieces
- in order to get cooked in the time.
- To get it in there.
And also it's lovely to come across
the little pieces of apple in the sponge.
I'm now going to fold the flour in.
Folding in, you should do very carefully to keep the air in.
Add the chopped apple to the sponge mixture
and roughly chop 75 grams of pecan nuts
which will go into the sponge and the sauce.
The toffee sauce has cooled. I'm going to put half of that
into the basin, give or take,
then I'm going to put half of these pecans
over the top of the toffee sauce.
And then in goes the sponge mixture.
Put it in carefully to start with from the side,
because otherwise the sauce will bubble up and mix with it.
The bakers all made their sponge puddings in individual ones,
and if you're going to make these individual ones,
sort of that size, it'll make about eight.
So just press that down all the way round.
Then I'm going to just put a disc of non-stick paper there.
Because of the apple you don't put the acid next door to the foil,
because there's sometimes a reaction.
It can even go pitted if it's cooked for a long time.
To make a lid for the basin, cut a square of foil
and fold a pleat into the centre.
This will give you room for the steam that will be created.
Seal the foil all the way around the basin so that no steam can escape.
Once it's covered with foil, it's ready to go on the hob
to be boiled or steamed.
But first of all, I'm going to put a little cradle round it
so I can lift it out of that pan.
To make the cradle, fold a thick strip of foil
so that you can lower the pudding basin into the saucepan.
First place it on a jam jar lid so that the pudding basin
won't directly touch the base of the hot saucepan and crack.
Then the foil cradles and it's really easy to lift out of the pan,
and make sure the pan is tall enough to take the basin.
Carefully pour boiling water into the saucepan,
about half way up the pudding basin.
I'm going to put the lid on.
But do keep checking it
because the water can go low. You can do it in a steamer,
it might take a little longer in a steamer than in simmering water
and it will take about two and a half hours.
Whilst Mary is steaming her pudding on the hob,
the bakers explore other ways of baking their puddings.
When it cooks, it creates a skin.
Doesn't sound all that appetising.
Three things going on at the same time there.
Pouring, dipping, mixing.
Oh, look at those! They look good.
Oh, my giddy aunt!
Ohh...oh, no!
I could cry.
Just lift it out, and we take off that lid.
You see, it's a lovely colour, isn't it?
It's that muscovado sugar gives it that flavour.
Let's just see that it's done.
You see, the knife comes out completely clean
and so put the plate over the top like that,
and don't turn it out until you actually need it.
I rather like turning things out, I like the surprise.
It's still very hot, there it is.
- Lovely.
- You can see the pecans there, but it hasn't got that shine.
The sauce has gone in to make the top very moist.
Add the rest of the pecans to the remaining half of the toffee sauce
and pour over the sponge.
And let it just trickle down.
You can make this the day before and let it get stone cold
and then reheat it again in a pan of simmering water.
It will take about an hour to re-heat.
So there we are.
Toffee, apple, pecan pudding.
I'm looking forward to this one, Mary.
Good enough to eat, that. Superb.
Dig in and see what you think.
That's wicked, that. You've got the texture of the pecan,
you've got the flavour of the toffee
and you're left with this beautiful flavour of apple.
It's a lovely sponge.
Mary's top tips on creaming, whisking and folding.
Creaming is just beating,
and I'm using a wooden spoon
but you could use an electric beater
if you're in a hurry. Add sugar,
just give it a good beat.
As you go on beating, it will get a lighter colour.
The principle of whisking
is getting as much air as I can into the mixture.
Choose a whisk that's got quite a lot of spirals in it
and you'll get a quicker result.
The bigger the bowl, the more volume you can get.
When it comes to folding,
it's important to keep the air in the mixture.
Round the outside of the bowl and cut through the middle.
Get right to the bottom of the bowl, right round the edge,
cut through the middle.
The aim of folding in is to keep all the air in
that you put in there originally.
So it's well worth doing it carefully and following the recipe.
Week Seven of the Bake Off,
and the bakers were struggling with sweet doughs.
They made show-stopping enriched dough loaves
and the technically challenging
fairground favourites, jam doughnuts.
The pressure was on,
and it was the Signature Challenge that proved difficult.
So, today we'd like you to make 24 regional buns.
They can be Bath buns, Chelsea buns, Colston buns, Devonshire Revel buns.
- So, on your marks.
- Get set.
- Bake.
Lardy cakes I'm making today, which is similar to Chelsea buns
except for you put piles and piles of lard in it,
so not exactly healthy.
Because I'm from South Yorkshire
and close to Bakewell, it's actually Bakewell inspired.
I'm making Easter Chelsea buns. Basically hot cross buns, Chelsified.
But Paul is keeping it classic.
His signature regional sweet bun is the Chelsea bun,
an enriched swirl of dough,
encasing chopped sultanas, apricots and cranberries,
layered with a gorgeous orange icing.
I'm going to start by making the base dough.
Can I have 500 grams of strong white flour, please?
You certainly can. And you always use strong flour?
Most yeasted breads would be strong white flour.
Seven grams of fast action yeast.
Pop in one egg. While I'm doing this,
could you weigh me up 40 grams of the caster sugar, please?
Along with the sugar add 25 grams of softened butter,
then add a teaspoon of salt but don't put it next to the yeast
or it could de-activate it.
That's all the key ingredients,
except for milk, which has been warming nicely.
Because it's an enriched dough, because it's got yeast in
and eggs and sugar and butter,
that tends to what we call retard the yeast,
prevent it from working to its full extent.
So warming up the milk actually helps activate it more.
Then get your spoon in there.
Could I do this with a dough hook?
Course you could. If I'm not around, Mary, you can use a mixer.
Well, we don't all have the energy and the skill
that you've got with bread-making.
It's not energy, it's technique, it's very simple to do, I mean,
enriched doughs have been around from Tudor times, you know.
Enriched doughs I think are so lovely,
all the croissants and Danish pastries and things like that.
Oh, yeah. If I get my hand in there now.
- I didn't think it would be long.
- A bit of flour for me, please.
And I'm going to dollop this mess into the middle,
coat it all round with some flour
and then begin to shape it into a ball.
The first thing that's happened is
you're incorporating all the ingredients.
The second thing is kneading builds up the gluten
for the air to be able to sit inside the sack that it creates.
You carry on doing this for about five minutes and it will get smooth.
When you're using a plain dough,
you very often put olive oil on the table.
- Yes.
- And when you have an enriched dough,
it seems to me that you put flour on the table.
I put flour on the table, yes.
Now once you've done that for five minutes,
you see how smooth it's gone.
Now that needs to rest. Pop it straight in the bowl.
No oiling round underneath?
This is an enriched sweet dough.
The last thing you want to do is add olive oil.
- Just nothing underneath it?
- Just leave it alone.
Ambient temperature we've got it at the moment.
It's got not much wind so you can leave it uncovered.
Pop that to one side for me and we'll leave that for about an hour.
It should double, if not treble in size in that time.
But the bakers had to prove that they had what it took
to make their enriched regional doughs.
This is such a sticky dough because it's got eggs and butter
and milk in, it's not like normal white bread dough.
I don't really know about the science but it seems to work.
You'll let it relax for five minutes and then you start to knead it.
During that time it will absorb more of the moisture and the liquid.
Holds its shape well.
It needs to double in size to prove, but it's too soon to take a look.
I'm just worried. That's why I just keep on looking at it,
but, I mean, it's too soon to actually really tell.
- You can see how much it's grown.
- It has.
I'm using flour on there and I'm going to tip this dough
onto the bench and just coat it in a little bit of flour to start with.
I'm just going to roll this dough out.
What I'm doing here is actually making the base
to roll up like a Swiss roll, you know, or a roulade?
And then this bit here I just tack down to the table all the way along.
Now I've got some butter here, it's about 50 gram.
I'm going to leave some back
to grease the tin I'm going to bake it in,
but slap that in the middle and get your fingers in there.
None of this sort of palette knife stuff, use your fingers.
And the doorbell rings?
Doesn't matter, let them wait.
Smear the butter all over the top,
I mean, this really is an enriched dough.
I love your tip about fixing it to the table
just by pressing your fingers into the dough and making it stick.
Yep, it works.
Now I've got 75 grams of soft brown sugar, scatter that over the top.
Like so. And when this melts it will almost caramelise in the oven.
Weigh out 100 grams each
of currants, dried apricots and cranberries.
Sprinkle two teaspoons of cinnamon all over the sugared dough.
Thank you very much, Mary. Just give that a bit of a mix
and then scatter these all over the top,
so they're nice and equal.
Put a bit of pressure on them to push them into the dough.
Now you start rolling it up, you get your dough
and then you begin to fold over the top bit as you would a roulade.
Then the next bit.
I think this is where people go wrong.
They're not bold enough when they roll up.
Now you are doing that quite tightly and firmly, pushing it down.
Yeah, and you can see you stretch it slightly
cos it's tacked to the table, it's not going to go anywhere.
Now when you get to the end you just quickly roll up
and all the tacked bit down at the bottom just release.
That will now bond with the rest of it, which you pick up
and drop in the flour, that way you can roll it slightly as well.
It doesn't really matter if a bit of the fruit's coming through.
- Once you've cut it all up it'll stick together anyway?
- Exactly.
But a different story was unravelling in the bake-off tent.
The hardest thing about making 24 sweet buns
is probably making them all the same.
Stop measuring the sausage.
OK, so here we go. One, two.
One, two.
There's absolutely no technique to this at all,
I don't know what I'm doing, basically.
I'm just worried cos this isn't very, very soft.
The dough might not actually hold.
Stop fiddling with them,
or else they'll just never be done, will they?
This is the danger points for me. Folding these are taking for ever.
You could have made a lovely simple pin wheel. What have you done?
I should have done Chelsea buns,
I knew I should have done Chelsea buns.
Just trim off the ends and you end up with the perfect Chelsea bun,
filled with all the fruits. Now, you're going to get 12 from this,
so roughly make a halfway mark,
- you've got to get roughly six from each.
- No ruler for Paul Hollywood.
And cut all the way through, rubbing the table
to make sure that you've broken it all the way through.
And there's your 12 Chelsea buns.
OK, I'm going to bring my tin in, this is a loose bottom tin.
Now I've got the butter that I left over before.
Grab that in your hand. Get it in there,
then smear it round the bottom. I'd advise you don't use oil on this.
It's essentially a sweet dough, so why would you use olive oil?
Butter's fine and you get a nice flavour from the butter as well.
So rub it round into the corners.
And I would say that's about a 12 by nine tin
and if you haven't got that tin,
- you could use a small roasting tin.
- You can, as long as it's clean,
if it's dirty and it's had a big roast in it from Sunday
and hasn't been cleaned properly, and I've been accused of that...
- Why are you looking at me like that?
- I'm not!
Your roasting tins I imagine are spotless.
I've got all my 12 lined up.
Pick them up and then drop them
and I'm going to do four rows of three like so,
spread them out evenly, put a bit of pressure on them.
So press them down a bit.
It stops them from rising up too much that way,
because it's quite a soft dough so they tend not to balloon up,
they do tend to flow out.
So that will fill all those gaps
and you end up with square Chelsea buns, so at this stage
they need to rest for at least an hour.
If it's in a draughty environment cover it up,
but if it isn't just leave it as it is.
Look at them, Mary.
They've spread beautifully into the corners.
The rest of those gaps will be filled while it bakes,
so it will start to grow a little bit more.
They're going to go into an oven. 200 fan, 220 non,
for about 20 to 25 minutes until they're lovely and golden brown.
When baking enriched doughs you must be careful not to burn the top,
which can colour very quickly because of the amount of sugar
and butter in the dough.
Good luck little buns, good luck.
So the bakers had to watch them closely.
That's the one.
Oh, they're robust, we're all right.
Really, really rather fancy. They're absolutely huge.
They just look so pale.
These look awful, what's wrong with them?
He's going to say they're under-proved, they're under-proved.
I'm quite pleased with them actually, I'm loving this sugar.
- Look at those fellas.
- They look wonderful.
All the fruit inside, it's a lovely colour
and it's filled all the gaps, see.
Now, while they're warm I have to finish these off.
Warm and sieve some apricot jam and brush it across the buns.
- Gives this a lovely shine as well as flavour.
- It does.
And while it's warm it just drips inside the Chelsea bun as well.
They smell fantastic and that sugar is caramelised inside,
gives it a beautiful flavour.
Now what I'm going to do is put some icing on this as well,
I'm going to make an orange icing so icing sugar, a spoon full of sugar.
I'm going to burst into song now.
We need Mel and Sue, they're always bursting into song.
It's very quiet in the tent isn't it, without them?
Now I'm going to get a zest of one orange.
So often we're eating the orange and we don't do anything with the zest.
It's a perfect way of using it.
A little bit of orange in there is beautiful.
Add just a little splash of water to the icing sugar to start with.
If you try and add too much water it just goes to liquid
and it doesn't all mix in. It almost looks split.
It's easier to start with a stiff bowl
and then weaken it off slightly.
Make sure you've got all the icing sugar in there,
then you break it down a bit.
Beautiful flavour, this orange icing.
Now look at the consistency.
- Just pouring.
- Lovely.
- See, it does hold slightly.
And that will just drip down again with the apricot jam,
it will go in the gaps.
Exactly. And then just dab all around.
It gives an unusual colour.
It's normally white icing you have on the top, isn't it?
Yeah, I like to be something different,
and that little bit of orange goes really well
with the Chelsea bun.
You see it, drips down the cracks. That will be extra flavour.
Absolutely, yeah. It's fantastic this stuff, it really is.
It's got a loose base. Pop it on the top,
and then force down the outside.
Look at that! What a beautiful bake!
That looks wonderful. Then just tear and share after that, isn't it?
Exactly. So what you've got there are my Chelsea buns,
topped with a gorgeous orange icing.
Looks so tempting.
Would you have put me through if I gave you them on the Bake Off?
I'd give you ten out of ten.
Well, nine and a half.
Now, I'm going to rip into this fellow here.
You've left the pieces of apricot chunky and masses of fruit.
That's quite something, really good.
Follow the recipe originally
and then begin to tweak the flavours to the way you like it.
If you don't like orange, use lemon.
Use lime if you want.
You can change the fruit inside. You could put nuts in there.
I think you could actually do the same thing with any of our bakes.
But first of all follow what we say from beginning to end,
and then you can start to experiment.
And all we've done is help people onto the entry level of baking
and then send them on their way.
And good luck.
Subtitles by Red Bee Media Ltd